مشاريع حفلت بها اجنده بوتين تاخرت لعقود
في زمن السلم لكنها تحولت انجازات في زمن
الحرب فرايس روسي لم يجد ما ينافس كفاءه
الحرب في تشكيل تاريخ روسيا والعالم
وفقورن هوليسي ورغم ارهاق القوات واستنفاذ
الموارد وتحقيق نتائج توصف احيانا
بالهزيله الا ان مشروع بوتين باوكرانيا
غير اي الانتهاء قريبا بحسب المجله
العريقه بوتين يستعد لحرب طويله يتمسك بها
لجلبها فوائد كثيره كالحد من اعتماد
التجاره الروسيه على الغرب وهو هدف لم
تحققه سنوات من السياسه والاستراتيجيات
ففي عام 2022
انخفض حجم التجاره للبلاد مع اوروبا باكثر
من النصف بينما نمت تجاره مع الصين باكثر
من اربعين في المئه كما تمكنت الشركات
الروسيه من تعبئه مواردها وتمويل مجموعه
من مشاريع النقل الموجهه نحو اسيا اهداف